[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in cell
israels heute gibt es süße sommer rollen
also frucht rollen sozusagen gestern
habe ich auf meinem kanal schon
herzhafte sommer rollen hochgeladen mit
einer leckeren gemüse füllung einer
richtig leckeren chili sauce die so ein
bisschen süß sauer schmeckt und auch
noch eine tag in erdnusssoße und da habe
ich mir gedacht mach' ich jetzt direkt
noch nur süße variante als einzel video
damit ihr sowas auch ganz schön fies
zubereiten können und die erste
komponente die ich zu bereiten werde ist
jetzt ein milchreis und da mache ich
jetzt in kokosmilch preis für den süßen
milchreis verwende ich 250 milliliter
wasser 100 gramm milchreis der ist
bereits gewaschen eine prise salz etwas
vanille extrakt 250 gramm kokosmilch das
ist die light-version und 30 gramm
zucker und jetzt gebe ich den
gewaschenen milchreis bereits mit dem
wasser salz und wann extrakt in einen
topf und lass das ganze mit deckel bei
hoher hitze und dann anschließend bei
mittlerer hitze für etwa zehn minuten
lang köcheln und wenn's wasser komplett
eingebracht es komme jetzt die
kokosmilch und der zucker dazu
dann einfach bei niedriger stufe weiter
köcheln und den herd irgendwann
ausschalten denn im großen topf zieht es
auch noch schöner ich habe ich jetzt den
fertig ab gekochten und abgekühlten
milchreis das schon fest eine manko habe
ich jetzt hier noch zum füllen erdbeeren
brombeeren blaubeeren und himbeeren
hier brauche ich natürlich auch noch
reis blätter die habe ich auch noch
übrig und kann das ganze jetzt zu
bereiten ihr könnt natürlich die karten
verwenden die euch am besten schmecken
ihr könnt auch kiwis mit reinnehmen oder
andere früchte die ihr gehabt ich gucke
jetzt ein bisschen dass es optisch aber
auch geschmacklich gut passt
normalerweise spiele ich eine kiwi ganz
gern am glas entlang aber heute möchte
ich sie
meinem glas entlang aber heute
wichtigste und die sind anders zu
bereiten und hobeln denn ich schlechter
jetzt gleich kleine blumen oder sterne
aus deswegen jetzt einmal so denn ich
brauche gleich eine schöne glatte
oberfläche er habe einmal zugesprochene
jutta
bei kiwi ist eigentlich nur zu beachten
falls ihr den milchreis nicht mit
kokosmilch sondern mit normaler mensch
macht dann muss die kiwis vorher hitze
behandelt werden denn da ist so ein
enzym drin und wenn das mit
milchprodukte in verbindung kommt
erkennt vielleicht vom joghurt wenn ihr
mal kiwi und gegessen habt dann schmeckt
das echt bitter auf der zunge und es
eben dieses enzym in der chemie und dann
muss man die vorher abkochen und hitze
behandeln und dann geht es kaputt und
dann kam käse und joghurt und
milchprodukte verknüpfen aber da mein
milchreis veganes weil er aus kokosmilch
besteht muss ich das halt machen und vor
allem benutze ich auch aspekte wie heute
also die mango hobel ich jetzt so 4 mm
dünn
müsst ihr natürlich nicht ob ihr könnt
und dann könnt ihr auch schön was
aufstellen
[Musik]
ich bin viel schöner könnte sogar essbar
geflogen das sieht auch schön aus
[Musik]
die adb schneide ich dann in schöne
scheiden schöne gleichmäßige scheiben
dann wird jetzt gerollt ich habe jetzt
hier meine reis blätter die einmal kurz
durch kaltes wasser ziehen
dann für euch hinlegen und ich möchte
dass man die mangos gleich sieht die
mango blüten deswegen kommen die jetzt
hier recht weit unten her
darüber ein paar schöne erdbeeren den
milchreis portion ihre ich jetzt mit
einem eis portionierer mit einem kleinen
da kann ich nämlich hier diese häufchen
so drauf setzen
und dann ist das schon schön geformt und
jetzt quasi noch zutaten die ihr gerne
habt also diese mintzel
kommt auch immer ganz gut
dann glauben und hin werden darauf die
band wird sich jetzt doch du schlägst du
noch mit rein es macht einfach welche so
oder so dann die seiten einklappen und
dieses kreisblattes zieht noch so ein
bisschen nach das heißt es wird nur ein
bisschen weicher
deswegen dürfte das auch noch zu lange
eintauchen und die meisten lasst uns
immer zu lange einwirken
ich legte jetzt hier auf einem
gefetteten blech ab damit sie einfach
nicht ankleben
[Musik]
die songs sind fertig die übrigen
erdbeeren könnt ihr einfach pürieren mit
bisschen zitronensaft vanille extrakt
und zb ein bisschen zucker wenn ihr
wollt
und dann habt ihr nämlich noch eine soße
zum dippen
wollen wir probieren hier
ist die auf
wo ich schreib mal uns eine auf
[Musik]
sie richtet mit dem süßen blüten ja in
seiner box sein
dass diese boxen diesem bento boxen und
diese sachen reich machen
war der schock ist oder aber vielleicht
auch
der milchreis
stoff das halt immer so ein bisschen
[Gelächter]
die unterscheidungskraft zu beweisen
ja richtig gut also probiert das rezept
wirklich gerne mal aus ich finds mit der
episode perfekt ist es sommerlich leicht
fruchtig und benzin davon ist joachim
berger ohne kinder so
ein bisschen
erdbeer himbeer soße
ja ich schreibe euch ich mich nochmal
himbeeren mit rein und dann mache ich
eine eher dahin beste draus ja für euch
also probiert gern aus das rezept findet
ihr in meiner app oder auf meinem blog
und falls ihr weitere asia gerichte
sehen wollt dann schreibt mir gern in
dieser sehr inspiriert muss man sagen es
so wird es das original dort
wahrscheinlich gar nicht geben aber so
davon inspiriert deswegen viel spaß
dabei guten appetit und bis zum nächsten
mal
auch mit glasnudeln und süß auch gut
fand oder schon probiert
gasmotoren praktisch wie gestern und
dann nur die früchte dazu ich möchte ja
eigentlich auch noch nicht
in der reis nur die eigentliche
papier heißt nun ja die auswahl
ich weiß es nicht mehr fahrbereit
[Gelächter]
[Musik]